matter you ready to go for a hike we
need to clean your little face oh honey
we're getting out right now just wait a
second okay so we're out here on a hike
and this is a dog-friendly hike so there
are so many dogs everywhere for little
Maddy he's getting so amped up so cute
so many puppies our little boy he stays
on a leash always oh this is an
elevation pull me up
my dog oh my gosh this is wrong
yeah Maddy I'm coming I said this in
Jenna's video but you guys were like why
does Jenna always had a dog like because
I'm vlogging so when she vlogs I take
him so quick Eve such enough we only
made it like maybe a couple yards I'm
exhausted
it's real pretty them how do you like to
try to pee on an incline how are you
gonna do this if you lift the leg you
fall over it's true okay let's go
we just started heading back from the
hike what should we do after this give
him a bath
yeah then play call of duty okay you
ready for bath after your snack we just
got back to the hike we're so disgusting
look at your new computer jazz it makes
sense to me it's honestly the worst
design that I've ever seen Apple to my
mouse oh it should be charged well I
know what that's done I know I know what
you did last summer
oh are you the contents of my fridge are
laughable coffee-mate orange juice
redbull fireball champagne eggs beer
Coffee more beer and coca-cola I don't
drink
I like there's no food in here
condiments like I hope you guys enjoyed
this what's in my fridge that this is so
sad
there's a fruit tray I'm ready to try
some strawberries some chocolate-covered
strawberries the Allison made these look
so good mmm
we're eating all those you ready for
your bath he's so gross right now you
know you're always getting the groomers
good money
we are having a Star Wars party for
Jamie's birthday so we're going to the
grocery store I already went to the
grocery store today and they did not
have any black icing Jenna oh I was
sitting there for 15 minutes just like
this what were you like I was like the
emoji eyes I thought these were matte
formats but dude wipes usually likes the
baby ones on something we're also gonna
go to the Disney Store to try to find a
present for JB he already has everything
Star Wars related yeah yeah I think we
can oh man we're here John we are here I
know I think I might need captain
phasma's voice changing masks I have a
stormtrooper one he just thought that no
he got kylo Ren he did not get phasma
hey where's all the rain toys not here
your puppy okay here's what we need is
there an extra extra large extra extra
extra large children's
and I agree a three that's like eight no
wait
I don't that's tiny do you think this
might fit here's the problem my own
I wish I was a toilet that's getting
smaller like look at this this could
potentially fit I keep hitting people
with my lightsaber we got two great
costumes for tonight this party's gonna
be so freakin wild I'm so amped up I
need to get black icing it fall off or I
love hot topic I've been in here so much
they've got so many good things that's
cute
all right so this is much later on in
the day I just shot a cooking with tylo
episode it's quite fantastic here's my
lightsaber haven't decorated the cake
yet because JB is bringing me black
icing and I think I might have said this
either in this video or in Jenna's video
I could not find any black icing it's
quite the struggle and I could make it
myself but making black icing is kind of
difficult so I've got lots of colours
this is for some future cooking videos
the cakes are cooking Jana's ordering
pizza I am so excited for this party
happy birthday JB Jamie what do you have
happy birthday well I got some stuff
it's okay my special night I brought
water oh my god yes so on um everything
you're ever Bankston like my brother
well with the soap and everyone needs to
be him at any time during the night I am
ordering that day tomorrow maybe or
maybe later the week you can be him um
what are we got going over here good
stuff
no she's nice did you miss the memo
summit oh is a minion yeah nope well I
gotta get that oh my goodness
Maddie you want a present baby boy looky
ah well all this is so great I like that
I love it now what have we got going on
over here who are you wearing
this is Jabba's palace yes this is nice
where I'm wearing these glasses to be
reminiscent of the slats they look
through
technically that's not Jabba's palace
Wow ten cups because I know that we're
gonna need these we will need those not
drinking out cups
yeah there's also this I could not find
that did to make the strong tree or take
it you take the case so I took the cake
without the chocolate basketball I'll
only food this is the best thing about
entire that's amazing
we're all not adults here at all going
on over here I'm eating lasagna out of
foil and champagne glasses classics AFL
I gotta take this costume off it is so
uncomfortable
that's what is your sponsor
nice this whole outfit is really good my
job then I become the bad guy when my
migraine goes away I become I succumb to
the dark side but right now magenta
no that's what we're listening to you
you gotta cross for Zach this is the
child a nine to ten year olds Christine
I had to cut it I had a cut it is it a
fun group please don't ever disrespect
she'd keep again problems what I lose
that so we need to take a quick hey cake
will do cake I made it Juliana pizza
salad okay because the worst cake ever
ah great do you want caffeine do you
want to coca-cola you want a mountain
Dew water and pepperoni pizza why does
that Grey Goose yeah Oh dad so good no
one don't have this music - you did a
wrong warm you can have whatever you
want
oh god I only have one on file handling
and killing the culture in this well
that is like ah I don't like this whoa
whoa now we use the force force blow
through the eye hole keep the cream nice
you have one leg okay we just ate cake
and I'm so full and now it's time to do
presents for Jamie we only have 2 3 X 3
presents but I did not wrap them so
basically I'm I'm going to hand it to
you is there a draft in here
accessibility yes yeah the air
conditionings on here you go here's your
first prize Oh Star Wars Episode seven
now in theaters soon DVD blu-ray ok do
you want your next present all of it yes
next one please
okay close your eyes I need to see the
eyes to know okay wait see the eyes
another close
do you like the horse yeah so what's
traveler ha ha ha here you earned that
I'll go to the airport tonight awesome
it's so great
oh my god oh the magic marker y'all that
was bad opinions is a proper universal
you first Universal Studios or Disney
pick one
hey everyone welcome to cooking with
kylo kylo Ren I am about to have a star
wars party and so my friends are gonna
be coming over so they're probably make
a cameo here partway through the video